hey we love guys my name is a Jonah
welcomed episode 37 of game programming
so yesterday or not yesterday last time
whilst episode we created this map that
we could actually scroll through and we
actually started rendering tiles the
correct way which was awesome now we
actually had a problem though with the
with the code and lost in last episode
and that is if we actually go out of
bounds of maps in other words if i
exceeded bounds
you know horizontally so in other words
if I go too far this way come on come on
I farted I frickin go let's just stop
this and yes I see if I try and go left
for example you can see that obviously
that is the top-left corner of the map
and if I try and go left even more it's
gonna return a negative index which
isn't going to work it's going to crash
our game as you see that it did now if
we actually debug this in you know this
so this the app Bulevar yes if you
actually diagnose this we can see the
way actually getting around excited
mouths exception right over here and
specifically what is out of balance as
tiles is well this X plus y times with
thing as you can see X is x over over
here is returning negative one which
isn't exactly working out because it's
trying to find tiles at negative one
which gives us you know right and Ryan
index out of bounds exception because
you know in in array indexes right into
would you say indices anyway array
indices I guess you would say because
you would say indexes not I think so
anyway the array index cannot be
negative and he said is so this is a
relatively easy problem to fix because
well there's obviously different ways
you can go about doing this up for now
though will probably simply say that if
we are out of bounds so in other words
if all other way if because obviously x
and y or what sort of give our um tile
things so if x is less than 0 right or y
is less than 0 then let's just return
tiled avoid tile all right so yeah if if
we go negative let's just keep returning
those blue void tiles so if I launch
this again and I go this way you can see
that we're just going to get a blue
a tile here and it's not gonna crash
because it's just it's just going to be
doing that and you can see that we're
still running very fast and everything
is still cool
so that fixes that problem one of the
problems the other problem obviously is
if we actually go out the other way so
if I patiently wait for me to get to the
end of the map
all right there we go so in other words
if we actually get
right right if we actually get out of
the the map that wise so in other words
if we exceeded so before we were
actually going negative which is going
less than the map I guess now we're
actually exceeding the tile index if we
actually take a look at that you'll see
that on the number of axes like 322 and
y59 simply too high and we didn't create
that many tiles so we can handle that in
much the same way all we have to do is
say that also if X is greater than or
equal to width or Y is greater than or
equal to height and we'll just resent a
void tile and that's it now one thing I
do want to mention real quick is you
must make sure that this code this if
statement that returns vital you must
make sure that this code is actually the
first code that is in the thing because
in other words if it was the other way
around so if that was first and that was
there obviously it would try and
evaluate tiles of negative one for
example and therefore crash right there
so make sure that the code that is
supposed to prevent it from crashing is
number one on the list all right so yeah
anyway that will make sure that if you
guys run out of the map you'll just
simply get void tiles as you can see and
everything will be awesome okay so next
time we're going to take a look at this
black border here and how to actually
fix that and make the map you know the
procedural map generation actually you
know be behind the scenes instead of
right in front of us but yeah anyway I
hope you enjoyed the steps up game
programming if you did please hit that
like button and I will see you guys next
time goodbye